le cinéma avec cette fresque
spectaculaire réalisée par ridley scott
le réalisateur de gladiator s'attaque
cette fois ci aux croisades film épique
où il est aussi question de tolérance
kingdom of heaven le royaume des cieux
parce qu'elle défend bernard qui se
souviennent qu'ils nous donnent réveil
nous replonge dans l'histoire des
croisades mais si elles ont duré quatre
siècles ridley scott s'intéresse à une
période précise en 1186 les chrétiens
occupe jérusalem conquise un siècle plus
tôt
un peu plus tard les armées musulmanes
maison chasserons entre les deux une
période de paix fragile que le film nous
fait vivre à travers un jeune chevalier
balyan élevé dans l'espoir d'une
jérusalem en paix croyant que la
confiance
un royaume des cieux chrétiens et
musulmans vivant en paix côte à côte ou
du moins sous le règne de sa la taille
du roi le moutier forçant tous
il y avait une période de lumière wii
domine parce qu'on peut appeler la
tolérance entre la deuxième et la
troisième croisade
et bien sûr elle n'a pas duré longtemps
mais c'est cette période que je voulais
explorer pour essayer de comprendre
pourquoi cela avait été possible est
face à face alors baudouin iv le jeune
roi de jérusalem ravagé par la lèpre un
pacifiste et le grand chef musulman
saladin sage et éclairée
ils vont chacun résister aux va-t-en
guerre qui dans chaque camp volt en
découdre chaque camp était divisée entre
modérés et sanguinaire entre faucons et
collants d'une certaine façon mais
s'appelle des dès le début vous savez en
1099 quand les croisés ont pris
jérusalem à la fin de la première
croisade il ya eu un bain de sang
terrible mais parmi les chefs croisés il
y en a plusieurs
dont le fameux tancrède qui ont essayé
par tous les moyens de s'opposer aux
massacres au péril de leur vie
à la mort du roi les pros les faucons
chrétiens l'emportent et une nouvelle
guerre éclate il là perdront il était
inévitable que certaines phrases du film
nous renvoient à des situations très
actuel les musulmans ont bâti leurs
lieux de culte sur les vôtres qu'y at il
de plus sacré le mur la mosquée le
sépulcre en dénonçant les fanatiques de
l'époque
ridley scott s'adresse à ses
contemporains tous ceux qui se servent
de cette histoire tragique pour
justifier les guerres d'aujourd'hui